all right begging the question fallacy
begging the question is a phrase we
actually hear a lot but it's misused
really often if we're wanting to be
accurate in terms of logical terminology
beg the question is often used to mean
raised the question or invoke the
question but begging the question
actually has a different meaning think
of begging the question as circular
reasoning which is another name for it
to beg the question is to assume in your
premise that your conclusion is true in
order for your conclusion to follow
you're assuming the truth of your
proposition which actually is what is in
need of proof you tell me
ghosts exist and you're sure of it I say
how do you know ghosts exist and you say
I've seen a ghost your premise that
you've seen a ghost
assumes your conclusion that ghosts
exist in order to remove the fallacy
your argument would need to look more
like this I've seen X X has been
observed and tested and confirmed by
credible means to be what we would call
a ghost
therefore ghosts exist or let's look at
a different example how do you know the
events described in this
thousand-year-old book actually happened
the book says there were many people who
observed what is depicted in the book
the person making the argument assumes
in their premise that the events in the
book are true which is also their
conclusion we should not grant an
assumption in a premise if the premise
is meant to be a means of proving that
exact same assumption that's where we
get the circle evidence to support the
assumption at some point needs to be
introduced people will often beg the
question by being sneaky and rewording
the conclusion in order to make it seem
different from the assumption made in
the premise fiscal conservatism makes
the most sense because it's the most
logical and coherent
economic philosophy making sense is the
same thing as being logical and coherent
the person making the argument is just
rewording the conclusion they're not
presenting any evidence for the
conclusion other than that which just
restates they're cool
many arguments that beg the question
when you boil them down to their basic
elements reveal only that the speaker
has an opinion on something which isn't
really an argument because it doesn't
provide any evidence having a conclusion
stacked on top of the same conclusion
doesn't get us anywhere as you might
remember from the beginning of the
series an argument requires a conclusion
and premise this miniseries is made
possible in part by hover when you're
setting up your website there are a few
important things to keep in mind first
keep all of your domains in the same
place you won't have to jump around to
different places to keep everything in
order and if you need to update them you
can do it all at once in the same place
second keep your hosting and your domain
separate if something ever goes wrong
with your web host and you need to find
a new one and you've registered your
domain with your host transferring your
domain can be a huge time consuming and
confusing hassle keeping your host and
domain separate also creates another
layer of security
even if hackers get a hold of your files
your domain will still be safe if it's
registered elsewhere this is what's
great about hover which is a fantastic
domain hosting service that makes all of
this possible
you can keep your domain somewhere
separate from your actual website which
makes managing a website much more
convenient and safe hover also has great
prices and they won't try to upsell you
they have hundreds of domain extensions
and they'll give you personalized email
addresses that match your domain they
provide a nice clean user interface
that's incredibly easy to use and their
support team is one of the best in the
business if you're setting up a website
or looking to transfer your domain keep
your domain separate from your host and
check out hover you can go to hover.com
slash Pakman for 10% off your first
order at checkout use the promo code
Pakman that's PA que ma n